we're going to turn this around so
instead of asking for a future value I'm
going to ask you for a present value no
okay here's the question
what present now you need to be invested
you don't need all the words for this
but I'll tell you that I'll read the
whole sentence anyway what present value
needs to be invested and here comes the
important numbers six point six percent
per annum compounded every half year
every part for five years if we want a
future value of $10,000 let me repeat
that
what present value needs to be invested
at six point six percent per annum
compounded yearly for five years if we
want to get to ten great does anyone
even repeat it again okay just have a
look at the web where did the question I
have where an ever so slightly
differently because I want to expose you
to some language which will be helpful
for you in the future I said that the
compounding period Baron read out the
question to you I said the compounding
period was hard for you okay now some a
way that that will get said to you half
yearly is you see the word biannual okay
now if you're like me I don't know how
many of you get confused with this but
annual means twice a year something you
should write down which is different and
you might see it is by any old does
anyone know what biennial means it's not
twice a year it's once every two years
okay so if I asked you to compound
something by any of you that means two
years have to pass and then they
compound and then another two years pass
and then they come down now I found this
really confusing and you'll encounter
this language that you need to know
which is which
okay here's the way that I remember okay
if you talk about something having a
scent eatery
that's usually a pretty old big right
like Australia had its bicentenary well
let's go say recently but it had its
Bicentennial in some in memory assent
Amazon which happens every can you guess
every hundred years right every century
okay so a since Henry a centenary
happens very infrequently that II sort
of sound means this is happening less
frequently whereas this means it's more
frequent okay so if you had try and your
that'll be three times a year if you had
try annual it would be once every three
years and it slows down does that make
sense so I always go back to this one
because if you had a centenary hundred
times a year
I'm just going to celebrate that okay so
I look at my commemorative coin nobody
another one in three days okay
so if you think about that way said
tannery means is a really long period of
time so if you see that by anyway I can
take Bicentennial that means it's less
frequent on the fridge okay can someone
help me up
what am I gonna write for the time you
can see I had to do two different things
what's the first thing I'm gonna run yes
okay okay so you want me to do interest
that's fine the order Donovan are so the
interest per half year that makes sense
so there are well there are two half
years every year right so that's going
to be five times two and that's why you
should have ten I'm sorry I'm doing the
time period sorry I need to do a three
like that it's zero point zero six six
that way and I divide that by two so you
can see this is actually caring what we
were mentioning before oh it's a nice
terminating decimal so I don't need to
turn that into a record there's no
benefit to them now getting ahead of
myself
now I'll work out the number of half
years there are we
renewing that's ten so which flow meter
am I going to use which what am I going
to use three we just yes this is exactly
why this is why we make a big deal right
notice you're converting it so that when
you do the next step
you get the number okay all right I see
you did zero point zero by which is fine
suppose you know what you're doing
what is the number by the way seven that
right yeah